let me ask a moral question sarah palin
in iowa was talking about stuff sir well
she was talking about her son in coming
back from iraq and she said like my son
like so many others they came back a bit
different and then just glossed over
that like we accept that now we send our
sons off to stupid wars and they come
back a bit different because he beat up
his girlfriend was talking suicide and
she blamed that on obama
and that's i'm sure why his girlfriend
was cowering under the bed because of
obama her her other her daughter has has
had two out of wedlock children i mean
does it ever occur to anybody that the
Obamas are just so much better parents
this is probably the area this is
probably the area where I'll give a
Bhama the most credit I think he's an
amazing father I think he's an amazing
father well so much think he's an
amazing president
well I don't agree with that but I do
think he's an amazing father and I think
that he presents a very good example for
Parenthood for many people I have a kid
who's and she's the worst the most
morally happy person going to Iowa to
convince the Evangelic 'el the
supposedly moral people well they suck
so bad because when you have the same
faith as me then whatever you do is off
the table right you watch you watch and
you're like what is what is she on and
then you realize oh the problem is she's
not on anything she looked like she in a
sober person talking like that she does
and she was reading did you notice that
she's actually reading at who actually
wrote that for a bunch of drunk monkeys
sitting at typewriters Rotax I will say
Sarah Palin is known to consume just
like the hugest quantities of
caffeinated drinks on the planet that's
a lot time on Red Bull I don't know